I'm going to take the region defined by
or the region in between the two curves
here between the yellow curve defined as
a function of Y as X is equal to Y minus
1 squared and this bluish green looking
line where Y is equal to X minus 1 so
I'm going to take this region right over
here and I'm going to rotate it around
the line I'm going to rotate it around
the line y equals negative 2 to get this
shape that kind of looks like the front
of a jet engine or something like that
and we're going to want to figure out
what its volume is and you can actually
approach this with either the disk
method or the shell method in the disk
method you would create disks you would
create disks that look like this and you
would be doing integrating with respect
to X you will have to break up the
problem appropriately because you have a
lower a different lower boundary you
would have to break this up into two
functions an upper function and lower
boundary for this interval in X and then
a different one for that interval in X
but you could use the disk method but
instead of that we don't feel like
breaking up the functions and doing all
of that so we're going to do it in the
shell method especially because we've
already expressed one of our functions
as a function of Y and this one won't be
too hard to do so what we're going to do
once again is imagine we're going to
imagine constructing constructing these
little rectangles that have height dy
and what we're going to do is rotate
those rectangles around the line y
equals negative 2 so let me draw that
same rectangle over here and when you do
that you construct a shell so let me do
that so it goes between those two points
and then we have constructed and so this
is what it will look like when it's down
here this down here and then let me make
it clear that this constructs a shell
this will construct construct a shell of
thickness dy or depth D Y so let me do
it like that so that's my shell and it
has some thickness to it and that
thickness that thickness is dy so that's
the thickness of my shell and let me
shade it in a little bit so there you go
make sure you see the
three-dimensionality of my shell so like
we've done with all of these problems
our goal is to really just figure out
our goal is to really just figure out
but the volume of each shell is then we
can enter for a specific y in our
interval and then we integrate along all
of the Y's of our interval and we've
done this many times before the first
thing we think about is what's the
radius what's the radius of one of these
of one of these shells so what I'm doing
right here in magenta what is the radius
of something like that
well we're it's essentially going to be
the distance between y is equal to
negative two y is equal to negative two
and our Y value for that specific Y
between y equals negative two and our Y
value for that specific Y so this
distance right over here this distance
right over here is y and then we're
going to have another two we're going to
have another two so the whole distance
is going to be y plus two another way of
thinking about it is this is essentially
y minus negative two to get the distance
which is going to be y plus two so the
radius of one of our little shells is
going to be y plus two if the radius is
y plus two then we know that the
circumference of that of this circle
right over here is going to be 2 pi
times that 2 pi times y plus 2 and then
the surface area the outside surface
area of the shell the stuff that the
stuff out here the outside surface area
of the shell is just going to be that
circumference x times the I guess you
could say the the width of this shell
times this distance right over here or
we could say times this distance right
over here and what is that distance
remember we want everything expressed as
a function of Y well it's going to be
the upper function as a function of Y
minus the lower function and we think
about the upper function is the function
is giving us higher x values in that
interval and so this blue function is
the upper is the upper function when we
think in terms of Y but we have to
express it as a function of Y so let me
do that so we can rewrite this as add
one to both sides you get X is equal to
y plus one so that is our upper function
and then this is our lower function if
you were to kind of tilt your head to
the right and look at it that way you'll
see that this will be the upper function
and this will be the lower function for
the same value of why this gives a
higher value of X then this one does for
the same value of I Y it gives the upper
bound the upper X values so the area is
going to be the circumference times this
dimension times this dimension so it's
going to be let me write this the area
the area of one of those shells is going
to be 2 pi times y plus 2 times the
distance between the upper function so y
plus the distance between the upper
function y plus 1 x is equal to y plus 1
and the lower function X is equal to X
is equal to Y minus 1 squared y minus 1
squared put the parentheses in that same
color and then if we want the volume of
that shell so we've got the outside
surface area of the shell right now we
just multiply it by its depth which is
just dy so that sets up our integral
that sets up our integral the volume of
one shell I'll do it all in one color
now is 2pi times y plus 2 times y plus
one minus y minus one squared and we
multiply that times the depth of each
shell dy and then we integrate over the
interval so the volume is going to be
this and what's the interval and you
might be able to eyeball it but we can
actually solve that explicitly when do
these two things equal each other well
you could just set y plus 1 to be equal
to Y minus 1 squared so let's do that so
if we set y plus 1 this to be equal to
that is going to be equal to Y minus 1
squared so let me expand that out that's
going to be Y squared minus 2y plus 1
and let's see I could subtract Y from
both sides and I can subtract 1 from
both sides minus y minus 1 and then I am
left with on the left hand side 0 and on
the right hand side I have y squared
minus 3y y squared minus 3y and well
that's it plus 0 which is equal to so 0
is equal to Y times 1
- three so the zeros of this when these
are equal or when Y is equal to zero or
Y is equal to three and we see that
right over here when y is equal to zero
these two functions intersect when y is
equal to zero and when y is equal to
three these two functions intersect so
our interval is going to be from Y is
equal to 0 to Y is equal to 3 so using
the shell method we have been able to
set up our definite integral and now we
can think about how we can evaluate this
thing